I'll try and get some weird rules where guns,
you guys like have a,
they bought up all the guns after a mass shooting,
right?
Is that what that,
well,
not all of them.
If you were a license holder,
like a shooter,
you had a shooter's license and you had a reason to have a gun,
then you can still keep your guns.
So you had to be like a member of a gun.
I don't own any guns.
But you had to be a member of a gun club.
I don't own any guns in Australia.
Uh,
you had to be a member of a gun club,
have we'll perhaps permission on a property where you're hunting and stuff like
that to keep your guns is that they keep trying to make it tighter and tighter.
I think it's tight enough because criminals are going to get what they want.
Right.
You know,
it's like how many people have been killed with a baseball bat?
Fucking heaps.
Are you going to be in baseball bats?
How many people who've been killed with a kitchen knife?
You're going to ban kitchen knives.
So I think if you've got a legitimate reason,
they have a gun,
you know,
like you don't have a criminal record,
you don't have a mental illness or something like that,
you should have a right to have a gun.
So you do basically do a safety course and training in Australia and if you've
got that reason to have a rifle and you can have it,
no semiautomatics um,
there's a bunch of rifles and there's a bunch of guns that you can't have in
Australia that's pretty much like bold action lever,
action.
And those rules might've changed as well.
No expert on obviously.
Whereas in America,
every fucking one's got,
like everyone I meet has got a gun.
I've got a gun too,
because if everyone else has got a gun and on a fucking gun to it's true isn't a
true and my guns for protection when I go into the Wilderness for bears,
or if I'm fucking in some weed destination and someone comes in and tries to
fucking rape or murder my family,
I'm going to use it.
And uh,
yeah,
it's just funny like that.
But it's crazy to think,
and I know it changes from place to place that you know anyone could have a gun
because you know,
it's like you're right.
And to a certain degree,
I agree with that.
But uh,
as well,
I think you lose that,
right?
If you've got a criminal record,
you've got a mental illness or something like that,
then fuck yeah,
exactly.
We want good guys with guns.
Not Bad guys have guns,
but ban on guns isn't going to stop the bad guys from having guns.
So weird.
It's like trying to take p out of the pool.
Yeah.
It's fucking so how when you,
when you hunt in Australia,
you're not allowed to use a bolt action rifle.
You can use a bolt action rifle.
It's like the automatic semi automatic,
I think an ar and ar.
Yeah.
I think pump actions are being taken out now,
things like that.
Yeah.